cette fois t'es foutu
c'est le président
toute cette monsieur le président
kane et je cours
on continue de l'appeler racketter stade
de fort boyard tournez manège et même
ces [ __ ] de téléfoot on lui
deviennent leur mascotte
quand il n'y a plus de solutions il est
la solution
depuis votre victoire contre les forces
obscures du football à racketter les
français ont tous été piqué par la
fièvre du tennis
mais cela a eu comme effet pervers
d'attiser la haine des autres sports
l'infâme double h a réussi à se mettre
dans la poche les différentes
fédérations
cette fripouille prévoit d'envoyer des
missiles rempli des cas surtout les coop
tennis sa prochaine cible roland garros
la télévision n'a d'yeux que pour le
tennis je vais bombarder les perrin de
gak hockey de
la tenue des couilles
et kaka
quand les méchants met les pieds sur son
terrain il reprend du service
râpez soulier
humilié
mais la partie n'était pas jouée
enfin tu sais bien que j'ai lâché le
manche non gestique des boules ça fait
mon bonheur [ __ ] mais qu ils m'ont
humilié comme jamais
c'était pire que dans le premier
racketter
ah ouais quand même
bon
je vais voir si je peux sortir l'avion
du garage
parce que peu coup sûr les boules aussi
maintenant il va distribuer les mauvais
points des prêts pour le futur
ces fleurons de la technologie française
avec ça tu peux regarder la météo
consult et des numéros aller sur 36 15
huila
ok t'es mitis balle 36 15
k
quoi
ça a duré que
dix mois
ça sent le finger bueno
à
inquiété ce match c'est ce qu'on lui
demande
et tom selleck
ce match
oh
kerry soir sa nouvelle raquette car je
connais tous qui courent
personne connaît racketter
chercher des noises à racketter ne
perdez jamais votre objectif de une et
rebondissait un bon moment
camping chaud
non